hello I'm Ryan right hello I'm Dan
Seibert today we're checking out a
gameplay first gameplay reveal for Doom
I saw another doom trailer recently but
then of course another one came out more
towards how III does it they don't
realize this trailer reaction business
is you know time-consuming if I put up
the first one without putting up this
one
people are gonna get upset wanting this
one so let's watch this good rant yeah
what are we getting gentlemen this is
doom goddamn right wha that's cheap look
I mean it's not but is reminiscent he
had us but it also reminiscent of the
old Fiat helmet to yourself oh [ __ ] yes
wow this is a lot smoother and prettier
than the last one that's ugly
oh my god so many dudes are about to get
rekt
that's what the king the asset kind of
scared ya likely over there on sir do
this there's certainly a little slight
level of horror dealer without ah even
oh go there it is
get it nice Oh like first-person Mortal
Kombat oh [ __ ]
oh my the brutal games love it I love it
it's [ __ ] violent as [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] awesome nice ouch
now wait stop what how does one even I
don't know he's twisted his ankle to
death then punch them how does one
deepen
sir and there's a thought he was
thinking was nothing the baby South even
got the old door sound cool
the level of brutality here is awesome
ridiculous I am loving the level of good
don't slip Jesus oh oh oh yes - on her
[ __ ] is classic not walking Doom put
the little shotguns away this is the
only shotgun you need he reloads a lot
faster than they can shoot him in I'm
mighty med this is 60 frames yes like
incredibly fast smooth it's hard to tell
because but I think it is
oh this guy this guy has no more feet
Pepper's plane misses have you always
been able to double jump
I haven't diseases these demons have a
really weak I like how the shotgun
doesn't always like tear them before I
didn't know punch will always be whoa
whoa wait oh thanks
I want that
all this dude
this is an awesome [ __ ] I'm okay with
love it you just
you you execute them so fast and in one
like fluid movement Oh always about the
rock at the rock is [ __ ]
oh please pretty [ __ ] sudol [ __ ]
place looks really chilly I will [ __ ]
play Oh
do this players amazing oh wow he
doesn't like the bullet no he's missed a
hole of like four shots
we'll take your glove off oh yeah one
would assume that would be the way to do
I want to kill hat
what's a hologram right well I mean yeah
but it's clearly leading you to uh where
the body is
that's rural scary set up
Oh
what'd he do that well he's dead and he
needs the hands for security cleaners
yeah I mean what else would you do I
mean you cut off the hand ER oh I was
like yeah
yeah
yes
and now we go
lastly wasn't expecting the chainsaw in
this game oh dude
classic what I know oh you know
I was gagged a little bit
they use want to do free Oh teen sites
and everything is Lisa
oh my god
and why are all of these demons not
running from this man I mean he's
clearly killing there is there's an
optical taking with it but first look
you said ice from it now I want to go
back to the chainsaw well I think that
could pop without it you can carry a lot
of weapons as men
Jesus Oh No
Oh what the hell my thousand experience
right there this is that was a [ __ ]
experience I'll tell you that man hey I
had a [ __ ] good yeah wow that was
brutal as all [ __ ] look it's been years
since I played doom Malcolm a lot I feel
like an idiot for now remember the
chainsaw I'm really I'm really stuck on
that yeah it's okay I'm really stuck on
that dude Doom one was and I still have
it on my xbox 360 i play play the hell
out of doom one that was brutish no yeah
it was [ __ ] brutal you know it's like
sure it's like doom but it's been like
what ten years since last doom has it
really been that long I think so I think
it's yeah I mean graphics are obviously
like really beautiful look at the 60
frames looks awesome and thick at 60
frames that looks great it looked 60
frames but the brutality is what I
really [ __ ] love you know you get a
lot of first-person shooter games these
days it's always like a cool Q like I'm
good aim and [ __ ] but I've never seen a
first-person where I'm like this is like
Mortal Kombat I'm blown away by how
effortlessly it was to just turn ankle
stop head with yeah it was like Rick
Rick no it's pretty [ __ ] sweet man I
was a great [ __ ] I like I desperately
want to play this game cuz you got like
the double-barrel shotgun
you got the chainsaw stun gun yeah the
guns are [ __ ] sweet I want to play
through all of the dooms leading up to
the ridge mass of this game just to like
see where it started you know what I
really like are the first person I mean
its first person of course but I really
like are the take downs like ankle okay
yeah go against patient ripping scored
head you don't usually get really cool
takedowns like that in our first-person
game so the fact that they're like doing
going all out with that was really
[ __ ] sweet I'm still just blown away
by the [ __ ] speed like a Gears of War
like chainsaw like execution thing you
know it's like it's like a whole event
that was like
like just a bucket rhythm it definitely
hasn't like horror-movie vibe in space
which is always freaky to me whenever I
see like a space horror film because
it's like you can't ya can't go anywhere
[ __ ] space so you know I mean one of
the big critiques of doom 3 was that yet
the flashlight you constantly had to be
like swapping between flashlights and
God and this one kind of like takes it
one step was like still there's like
some sort of like [ __ ] aspect to it
where you sometimes you don't know
what's gonna come at you but the same
time it's like once you get into the
[ __ ] it is an action [ __ ] kill
everything movie but the tease of that
monster through the hologram like that's
what I'm talking about or like if that's
suspenseful because this whole time
you're watching this guy play and he's
like [ __ ] everyone up and then at
that moment I was like oh this is gonna
be scary
and then he got killed by some random
random dude who just yeah has parkour
skills or some [ __ ] I mean normally a
trailer would end with like the guy
jumping at you and like the fists coming
up to like enjoy the player but this one
was straight up like hey this is how
gruesome your deaths can be boop boop
boop I love it love it I love what our
society has turned into anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the real rejects
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to this channel you can check
out Dan's gaming channel that's hyper
yeah and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and fun and if we get
enough fall Reserve we get product
placement for things such as notes notes
are great every once in a while you
might have to remember something you
write it down like hey this is the best
way to like a woman's [ __ ] so you write
it down in case you forget normally I
don't forget like my dick remembers but
my mouth sometimes doesn't cuz I could
be a selfish lover in bed sometimes yeah
notes up notes up just make sure you got
a little one on you because you can't
like without a huge piece of paper while
you're [ __ ] the girl or a guy so you
need a small notepad that way you can do
it discreetly sorry I'm back what I just
saying umm talking about Jesus okay